now it's time for the uplift at eight
where we share stories that will bring
you pure joy right to your day Christina
grafina is here what do you have for us
good morning guys so we have a story
about some small acts of kindness for
unsuspecting strangers let's take a look
sorry to bother you is it okay if you
can just hold these
have a lovely day
thank you
look at her face oh you can tell she
likes Harrison Pollock surprises
Australians with everything from flowers
to free food sometimes just a hug the 22
year old says he originally used social
media for pranks but decided to change
things up and make people happy instead
he doesn't just deliver those smiles to
the people he surprises but also to
Millions on social media and I will say
this morning to us
want to do my part to do something that
is going to help to make people be like
wow there's still faith in people like
people are still good
yes I believe that Christina people are
still good they say sometimes a great
thing is just a string of little good
things all put together like you know
just anything gets us through the day
that's right listen for all you aspiring
influencers that's how you go viral
exactly all right Christina thank you